there are nights I cried myself to sleep
like what just happened Kim Kardashian
might be a Bonafide entrepreneur reality
star and lawyer in training but she
admits being a mom is the hardest
business of all having kids is just
there's no way to describe it but it's a
lot Kim opens up on the on purpose with
the Jay Shetty podcast about raising the
four kids she shares with her ex Kanye
West nine-year-old North seven-year-old
Saint five-year-old Chicago and
four-year-old Psalm everyone says the
days are long and the years are short
and that couldn't be like a more true
statement it's the best chaos though I
always have to do one of my daughter's
hair and it has to be perfect and it has
to be a certain way and then this one
needs me to put his shoes on and that
they all need you it's like full crazy
Madness cooking running around like it's
it's wild that's why I need my workout
in the morning just to like prepare for
the two hours of craziness I do feel
like my house is so full but in the best
way I'd say parenting is the thing that
has taught me the most about myself
it has been the most challenging thing
Kim straight up tells it like it is
parenting is really hard there
are nights I cried myself to sleep like
what just happened with all the moods
and the personalities and
sometimes they're fighting and there's
no one there like it's it's me to play
good cop and bad cop that is definitely
a challenge when you know something I'm
working on is being a little bit firmer
of course Kim and Kanye finalize their
divorce last November after six years of
marriage and last year Kim got emotional
talking about the difficulties of
raising kids with her ex I don't want to
get emotional no it's just been a day
for me
but like it's been a time it has been
you know it's hard
it was like co-parenting it's really
hard you know since then A
source told ET that things between Kim
and yay are fine enough and she does her
best to maintain a good co-parenting
relationship with him I always think
everything in life comes our way to
really teach us something and it's a
really hard task when you have four kids
and you know they all want to be put to
bed at the same time by the same person
and they all want to do it individually
and have that experience and no one
wants to wait and I'm locked in a room
with kids banging outside of the door
because they want me to put them to bed
and I'm like I can't cut myself in four
pieces and they don't understand that I
work or I have a school schedule too and
all that Echoes what Kim told ET back in
2019. I want to make sure each kid gets
so much of my attention I think four is
the perfect magic number for me but
despite the challenges that come with
being a
prepare you anyone any person that says
oh we're waiting to
have X amount of money in the bank oh
we're waiting to have a home before we
have kids oh I'm waiting for this job to
come in before we have kids I don't care
how long you wait I don't care what
you're waiting for you are never
prepared but you will figure it out
and it will make you so proud of
yourself that you figured it out and
that you got through the day
foreign